with the runtime of 130 minutes thor
ragnarok isn't exactly a short movie but
it would have been a lot longer if
director Taika Waititi had gotten his
way much of YT tease method relied on
improv so he encouraged leading man
Chris Hemsworth to ad-lib with his
co-stars which meant that tons of
material they filmed didn't end up being
used in the final film while a good
chunk of that footage probably belonged
on the cutting room floor there were
some moments of pure gold that had to be
removed due to time constraints thanks
to the home video extras here's a look
at the scenes you didn't get to see and
thor ragnarok playing charades the grand
master played hilariously by Jeff
Goldblum teaches topaz the meaning of
hand signals in one extended scene which
carries on after Loki and Valkyrie are
tasked with capturing the escaped Thor
when they fail to understand the meaning
of his go signal he starts ranting about
all the ways to tell people to do
something without ever having to open
your mouth
this means code did you not get that
that's the universal sign it was I not
clear
heaven's sakes what did you make of that
he then proceeds to teach topaz about
the signals that he promises are
universal although she struggles to
grasp them what's this - I lit down
that's dialect out meeting the Grand
Master the Grand Master makes a bit more
of an impression on Thor in an extended
scene showing their first meeting the
scene begins with Thor freshly arrived
in the Grand Master's palace trying to
escape while the celestial being sends
his many followers after a frustrating
flying creature
after everyone else departs the grand
master tells Thor about the obedience
disks the chip implanted in his neck
that keeps him from escaping it's a
little invention of mine by the way you
know some people find it kind of erotic
you know this part the Grand Master
turns his attention to Thor asking the
hero to introduce himself with a great
amount of effort Thor identifies himself
as the god of thunder before the Grand
Master then takes Thor to see his
interrogation of his cousin Carlo his
crimes you said it was only a small
camels why did you do this small camel
after a bit more back and forth the clip
ends with Carlo being pardoned from life
Thor gets used to his new roommate
Thor and the Hulk make a pretty great
pair in Thor Ragnarok but they didn't
exactly start out on good footing after
their big fight the pair had to get used
to roaming together and an extended
scene of the two and their quarters
shows that figuring out how to get along
wasn't easy
the extended scene begins with Thor once
again trying to remove his obedience
disk the noise wakes up a sleeping Hulk
who has to shake off a bad dream that
seems to have involved Bruce Banner
trying to regain control of his own body
like the final film Hulk ultimately wins
out and starts pestering his roommate
for seeming sad Hulk antagonizes the
title hero and eventually knocks him
over before Thor caves to admit what's
bothering him and starts kicking things
around the room but if there's one thing
you don't mess with it's Hulk's necklace
and then Hoek lets loose with the worst
insult he can think of ouch scourge
finds Heimdall scourge went through a
long journey in Thor Ragnarok
going from an undervalued soldier to
Hellas executioner to the savior of
Asgard well the character was featured
quite a lot in the film there was one
scene that didn't make the cut
showing him finding one of hellas must
want it Heimdall in the clip scourge
appears to be trying to get his bearings
after Hellas destruction of the
Asgardian army when he spots a group of
people fleeing in the disk
he pulls out a pair of binoculars and
trains them on Heimdall he turns around
and looks directly towards scourge
before fleeing there's no word on why
the filmmakers decided not to keep the
scene as it would have hinted early on
that scourge would be willing to defy
Hellas orders if it meant saving his
friends still the movie worked just fine
without the moment and it made Scrooge's
eventual change of heart even more
surprising hope chases Thor through
Sekar Thor's escape from the
grandmasters headquarters was nothing
short of heroic in the film and a
deleted scene gives even more of a
glimpse of just what he had to go
through to get out in the clip Thor
jumps out the window of the Grand
Master's palace but he's followed by an
angry Hulk who wants him to stay poke
crashes through the marketplace greeted
with cheers from the locals everywhere
he goes he follows a somersaulting
running Thor throughout the colorful
City until Thor finally makes it to the
junkyard where he finds the former
Avenger ship there isn't much to the
scene but it shows more of Sekar and how
its people react to their champion which
starkly contrasts with how he's regarded
back on earth thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]